well it didn't rain much and it didn't
rain long but it rained long enough that
the tigers and white sox could not start
on time
in game two of a double header it's
matthew boyd against dylan cease their
young right-hander in the nightcap
dylan cease there you look at the
numbers this year he does not have a
decision this is fifth start
17 in the third he's walked 12. that is
not a good number left handers haven't
done much with them strangely enough
it's the right-handers that have hit him
very well
know balls two strikes to the former
minnesota twin among others robbie
grossman
02.
breaking ball hit in the
air first base side jose waits for the
arrival about number one tonight
newcomer to the lineup harold castro
[Applause]
curveball grounder up the middle
good range by anderson but not in time
an infield single
for harold castro
one on one out miguel cabrera and a
ground ball would be really nice
high fastball busts miguel cabrera
and dylan cease
is in it to win it tonight a lot of
strikes well cabrera's really hot but he
just got overpowered with some high heat
he's not a happy man
first pitch breaking ball sky high to
right
garcia is under it and dylan cease has a
13 pitch
first inning and no score after a half
let's take a look at matt boyd looking
good two and two could be better
here at 182.
he's just made a lot of changes
this guy has went to work and throwing
the ball as good as you can throw it
right now
tim anderson three home runs 15 for 42.
that's a fastball tim bloops it to
center field and this is down
a parachute
to open the bottom of the first
and his hit streak was broken in game
one he starts another one here robert
who's been off the last couple of days
with flu-like symptoms ready to go
tonight another 2-2
that's a beautiful thing
strikes out robert for the first out of
the night
the 3-2 man he struck him out
back-to-back outs from matthew boyd two
away in the chicago first watch how hard
his arm comes through
great arm speed
the one
swinging
sending it to deep right field victor
reyes has got enough room to put it away
like the tigers stranding two in the
first chicago does the same against
matthew boyd here comes detroit in the
second led by willie castro
fastball on the ground tim's on the hunt
madrigal goes down in order to give tim
a lane and there's out number one well
that is really close at first base here
is akil badu
it's a lot of clapping going on at the
ballpark do you think they're exhorting
dylan cease to strike that bad dude i
think it's about fields really i think
it might be it might be for cease it
might be both
badou takes a splitting slider for
strike three fairly well akil badu
enough confidence in the slider to throw
it three and two and
he put it right there two down victor
reyes third straight breaking ball oh
and two
he struck him out
back back-to-back strikeouts for dylan
sees
two and one from boyd
and rouhan ticketed for left-center
field up the alleyway and it stays in
the ballpark rondall to third to a stop
sign and the sox have second and third
andrew vaughn starting to hit the
baseball at the game earlier in the home
stand he just smoked the ball and
there's a double this young man hits the
ball hard something's wrong with matt
boyd
he made a motion to the dugout ramos
quickly and now aj hinch and chris
fetter and doug teeter the trainer out
talking to him he's leaving the wall
game 36 pitches deep something happened
to matthew boyd and now larry garcia has
a rare at bat where he's hitting from
both the right and the left-hand side
over second and down that's going to
give the sox the lead stop sign at third
for vaude larry garcia punches another
one to the outfield and it's one nothing
socks
now nick madrigal
nikki two strikes
two nothing socks
it's truly otherworldly what he does
with one strike left and the socks have
loaded the bases for jose abreu
jose to left field that should get two
home
garcia touches nick madrigal has run
number four and abreu
pays off bases loaded again
to his own applause
the one-two
that was a great hook for strike three
for dylan cece
that gives you an idea of just how good
this young man's stuff is
and now miguel cabrera
another slider
four of them
for miguel cabrera dylan
is 75 strikes one two
oh yeah
uncle charlie pays a visit one gone
so for dylan sees that seven in a row
retired
well that's good wonderful yeah he did
get out of here
seven strikeouts for dylan cease
fastball in the air right field
garcia at the wall oh leori garcia
what a running grab
yeah smile all you want
andrew vaughn skewers it to left field
for a three for three night
for the first round pick from a couple
years ago it's another double
for andrew vaughn
infield in against laori
the pitch
ground ball base hits center field
two runs will score
this double header has belonged to leori
garcia he's knocked in three in this one
luis back in the lineup after flu-like
symptoms for a couple of days
like that
into right field and rbi for robert
madrigal to second
sox have seven tonight in his
seven-inning bowl game
now johann moncada
joanne tags this ball to right it is a
dart that's gone
and this is a rocking first home run of
a long day but a very productive deck
is the dh mercedes
just gonna have to oh now high tower fly
deep center there's the hit it's a home
run
an absolute monster shot it's 11 to
nothing
two and two from cease he struck him out
a slider wafting through the breeze for
strikeout number eight three short of a
career high
as dylan cease has sent away 16 straight
tigers
breaking ball
get him strike three
first shutout of
cease's career
was artistry